dans la salle de montage yen se
concentre sur son projet en cours
il apprend ce matin à monter plusieurs
images sur son logiciel l'ennui sur du
msci caméra c'est c'est un nouveau truc
on va apprendre en fait pour un mini mac
je pense qu'il sera un grand projet pour
un prochain projet là qu'on a dans pas
longtemps dans quelques semaines comme
lui 1300 étudiants décidé de devenir
monteur réalisateur scénariste cameraman
ou encore son dié au campus 3 yes
plusieurs formations sont proposées aux
étudiants pour être opérationnels à la
sortie de l'école on reste attaché à
l'idée que le cinéma ont pour la prendre
il faut le faire tout simplement
donc pour faire du cinéma il faut avoir
les moyens techniques il faut avoir les
locaux il faut avoir des intervenants de
qualité il faut avoir vraiment un site
et des équipements dédiés à
l'enseignement du cinéma et
l'audiovisuel au sens large
donc nous
à saint quentin en yvelines on a deux
bâtiments on a plus de 14 mille mètres
carrés de surface d'équipements dédiés
et on fait vraiment sorte dans notre
pédagogie
au delà des enseignements théoriques de
la culture artistique des enseignements
pratiques nous notre notre démarche
c'est vraiment la mise en situation
professionnelle la création la technique
et la polyvalence sont les qualités les
plus importantes pour eric d'un tian
référent de la filière réalisation et
fiction pour s'adapter au mieux au monde
du travail mais aussi pour se démarquer
de ce milieu très sélectif quand on suit
une formation de réalisation fiction à
l'école on apprend à concevoir
un court métrage particulièrement mais
aussi d'autres aspects de la fiction
comme des séries c'est à dire qu'on
apprend à superviser des équipes donc
qu'on soit l'origine ou non donc du
projet on
chapote l'écriture et puis après la
constitution d'une équipe et toutes les
étapes de production jusqu'à la
finalisation du film donc on apprend à
diriger à concevoir et on apprend
surtout bas à employer ses moyens comme
une force et non pas comme une limite
apprendre à travailler en groupe est une
notion importante dans le cinéma car
pour créer un court métrage il faut de
nombreux intervenants pour avoir un
résultat final benjamin l'a bien compris
et prépare déjà son prochain projet avec
les autres filières celle en ce moment
on est en train de travailler avec
d'autres filières dont la production
le montage le son l'image l'assistanat
réa et les journalistes
le but c'est de ramener toutes les
filières et de les mettre ensemble pour
qu'on fasse une émission donc sur
plusieurs thématiques à la fin des trois
années d'études à trois aces 87% des
étudiants trouvent un travail
une école qui se développe grâce à ses
nombreuses formations et à ses campus
pour permettre aux étudiants des outils
d'apprentissage de qualité